هذا الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن اجتماعا
ثلاثيا مع رئيسي الوزراء الاسترالي
والبريطاني في قاعده بوينت لوما البحريه
في سان دييغو وهدف الاجتماع لوضع لمسات
الاخيره على اتفاقيه تزود بموجبها
الولايات المتحده استراليا بغواصات
تقليديه تعمل بالطاقه النوويه وذلك
استنادا لاتفاقيه اوكوس الثلاثيه بينهم
قلب ايضا ان الغواصات التي سيتم تزويد
استراليا بها ليست اسلحه نوويه بل هي
غواصات تعمل بالطاقه نوويه واضاف ان هناك
التزاما بالعمل المشترك لضمان بقائم منطقه
المحيطين حره ومزدهره وامنه
نعلن عن الخطوات اللازمه لتنفيذ مشروعنا
الاول في اطار اتفاقيه اوكوس لتطوير
القدرات الاستراليه في مجال الغواصات
المسلحه التقليديا والتي تعمل بطاقه نوويه
ولكنها لا تحمل اسلحه ذريه فاستراليا دوله
تفتخر بانها غير نوويه وهي ملتزمه بالبقاء
على هذا النحو
اما رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك
فقال ان الاتفاقيه تهدف الى مواجهه تحديات
جديده تفرضها دول على راسها روسيا والصين
واعلن سوناك عن زياده ميزانيه دفاع
البريطانيه بنسبه 42
ان الله
خلال الاشهر الثمانيه عشره الماضيه ما
الغزو الروسي غير القانوني لاوكرانيا الى
التحدي الصيني المتزايد وسلوك ايران
وكوريا الشماليه المزعزع للاستقرار وفي
مواجهه هذا الواقع الجديد من المهم ان
نعزز قدره بلداننا على الصمود ولهذا السبب
تعلن المملكه المتحده عن زياده كبيره في
ميزانيتها الدفاعيه سنصرف خمسه مليارات
جنيه استرليني اضافيه على مدار العامين
المقبلين ونرفع ميزانيه الدفاع فورا الى
اثنين وربع في المئه من الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي
بدوره قال رئيس الوزراء الاسترالي انطوني
البانيس ان بلاده ستتسلم ثلاث غواصات
امريكيه تقليديه من طراز فيرجينيا تعمل
بالطاقه النوويه مع بدايه العقد الجديد
اتفاقيه التي نرسخها هنا في ساندييغو اكبر
استثمار منفرد في تاريخ القدرات الدفاعيه
الاستراليه واعتبارا من مطلع العقد المقبل
ستستلم استراليا ثلاث غواصات تعمل بالطاقه
النوويه من طراز فيرجينيا وهي المره
الاولى منذ 65 عاما والثانيه في التاريخ
التي تشاطرنا فيها الولايات المتحده تقنيه
الدفع النووي